every month it's 560 hours per month
it's totally free I don't need to do
anything for that I am a free man
[Music]
artificial intelligence and robotics are
advancing at a remarkable rate now
they're matching humans and even
outpacing us today
technology and automation are
eliminating many jobs more than 10
million UK workers are at high risk of
being replaced by robots within 15 years
luckily Silicon Valley thinks it has a
solution for the destruction it's sowing
what to do about mass unemployment we
should explore ideas like universal
basic income I think ultimately we will
have to have some kind of universal
basic income to make sure that everyone
has a cushion to try new ideas universal
basic income is the dramatic and
controversial remedy and Finland is
trying it out here's the idea scrap the
welfare state instead every man woman
and child receives the same cash payment
from the government every month whether
they have a job or not
whether they're wealthy or not that
might sound wildly utopian but for 2,000
unemployed people here it's become a
reality they get 560 euros a month and
there are no conditions money for
nothing well they're experimenting with
here in Finland is something quite
radical in the face of technological
mass unemployment the idea that income
that money could be a fundamental human
right
those 2,000 people were randomly
selected to take part in the trial and
they're scattered all over Finland Juha
javelin is 39 years old and a father of
six he lives in a small town in the west
of Finland where a factory after factory
has closed in January he received a
letter telling him he had been selected
to take part in the universal basic
income experiment
he'd been unemployed for five years
after going bankrupt excellent there is
a couple of years I think it's like a
black hole in my head
I was just hoping that who'd die and and
but quite a quickly after that like the
bankruptcy I I started to decide
something something on and again stead
maybe the old business again jeha
actually receives less money on the
basic income experiment than he did on
unemployment benefit the difference is
more than a hundred euros a month he's
happy though because of the flexibility
it affords he doesn't have to take
menial work or even look for a job
instead he carved his traditional wooden
drums and sells them on the internet for
me a lot of freedom I feel that I'm out
of slavery slavery of the system and I
am again a free man and free citizen
in Helsinki the Technology Expo offers a
glimpse of the future one without much
room for humans nearly half of all jobs
in the US could be lost to automation
according to researchers and what
University in the UK a third of jobs are
at risk according to the Bank of England
a total of 15 million fears about that
jobless future means universal basic
income is popular in Finland at least
conceptually when you get down to the
details and some of the people on the
scheme it becomes more controversial see
neat Marten n was another person who
received a letter she was unemployed but
she's well educated and has savings and
since the trial started she's found a
new job but still gets the income
Finnish people are the only one who are
willing to give a hundred so that your
neighbor doesn't get a fifty and that
kind of that kind of atmosphere here is
it's always you're taking from somebody
else but Cini says that basic income
gives her the flexibility to look after
her father who has Alzheimer's
I can plan my work so that okay I get
their 560 then I work a little bit more
so I get all my expenses covered maybe
can't even save a little bit and then
but with this 5560 I can also take I
took like a week off not working so I
could do volunteer work the trial
finishes at the end of 2019 even when we
get the results though there's a
question over the universal bit of
universal basic income can an experiment
being run in a small Nordic nation
really be applied to very different
societies and economies around the world
you do some experiments where you think
about how it might work in practice what
the funding models look like started
introducing slowly alongside the current
system or even as part of the current
system the political barrier is always
significant when you have a radical
change and to the tax and benefit system
it takes time and political
determination to do it it's interesting
to some extent that what with what we're
not concentrating more is how to get
wages rising what
actually happens to people who are in
work which is the current situation of
most people and almost kind of talking
about this slightly futuristic separate
thing of well what if all the jobs
disappear what would we do then the
problem at the moment isn't really a
lack of jobs we've got the highest
levels of employment we've seen at least
since we started recording it in this
way in the 70s not ever but you know we
have got pretty high levels of
employment the real problem we're facing
is low wages this frozen drink company
has made a big bet on technology
investing three hundred thousand pounds
on these packing machines what we used
to be able to produce in a day aquino
could use in a couple of hours and as we
commissioned them further we bring you
to move on an hour I mean the robot you
know the robots I would say of
complementing the skills we already have
and the humans will upscale into
slightly different areas the company a
hard a full-time highly skilled
facilities engineer and that base in
northumberland they say that employment
and technology can be complementary that
also includes coming up with a new way
of monitoring and controlling their
drink machines and leisure centers and
theme parks around the world remotely
we're able to operate and keep the
machines running without having an
engineer pop in and visit all of the
time few humans employed it's it's
helped us expand and it helps us pay
better
it helps us look after our customers
better and look after our staff better
and it does mean that we're able to
employ different varieties of stuff so
instead of employing eight engineers we
employ people here to monitor the
machines which means that it's a
different level of stuff without the
guys on the road without a couple
investments involved in that
Scotland was one of the engine rooms of
the first Industrial Revolution now is
planning to be the first place in the UK
to introduce universal basic income
Friday night in Fife and one occupation
that's unlikely to people replaced by
robots the council here is planning its
own basic income trial it wants to go
further than Finland and apply it to an
entire town giving up to seven thousand
pounds to everyone in it no matter their
age or employment status it gets a mixed
reaction here if they're capable of what
can I believe they should be doing
community based tasks for the extra
money I don't believe you should be in
people money fund anything unless that's
abled all too old Danny okay fair dues
I'm gonna count into trade so I usually
work for a company so used to look at
Costco and then sometimes machinery was
a better option because it can run 24/7
where staff can't be in an employee at a
certain fast-food restaurant we've
recently got in these kiosks where
people can place their orders so it's
taking a lot of sort of pressure off us
what the tools but it does take away you
know what a few people have lost their
jobs and stuff because of it the money's
good because it's immediate in that gap
between employment and unemployment but
him you know why makeup camera things I
mean you're I try and get me up drugs
gone five council is still in the design
stage it hopes to have a trial ready for
2019 applying basic income to a town
called a saturation site lets you study
its effects on an entire population and
understand its net impact we're looking
within central Fife here these are areas
where the with Ana living memory we've
seen the demise of coal industry demise
of heavy some heavy engineering and
paper mills and things that were you
know key to employment in these areas
and that's probably where we find higher
incidences of poverty we want to find
out what what impact that has on
individuals we want to find out if you
have an unconditional payment what sort
of act
it is what sort of jobs are you prepared
to actually undertake what sort of
further contribution to society would
you actually make because you're not
having to worry about making ends meet
you've got this basic income to rely on
and therefore what some of the behavior
changes that we actually explain this
the Scottish Government has pledged
funding for fights plans along with
Glasgow Edinburgh and airship and
there's one of the big questions for you
me I how do we actually pay for it all
the cost of basically can will be more
than the current system you have forward
in a lot of the current elements of the
welfare state and a tax system into a
basic income they will still need to be
an additional sum and on top of that
probably wants two percent of GDP which
is significant people's lives are quite
complicated and one of the disadvantages
of the universal basic income is in
light I don't think we've yet thought of
how to deal with some of those
complexities so for example around
housing costs for example that extra
costs if people find it harder to work
perhaps because of a disability and so I
think you know the kind of advantages
are often some of the disadvantages as
well the effects of automation have been
so rapid that government has been left
flat-footed the next Industrial
Revolution is under way white-collar
jobs are just as threatened is bloomed
EBI has its supporters and detractors on
both sides of the left-right political
divide but experiments like those in
Scotland and Finland an attempt to be
more proactive to at least get data on
the sort of society we might choose to
make everyone work enough work for
everyone you just have to try to inspire
people somehow to be creative and do
other kind of stuff otherwise you will
have a lot of different kind of social
problems that will be very expensive
more expressly expensive than the basic
income system
what's up for grabs here isn't just the
sort of jobs we do but the sort of lives
we live
yeah